so
so
so
so
okay
okay
so
testing one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
ten
testing 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20
19 18 17 16
15 14 13 12
11 10 9 8 7
6 5 4 3 2 1
testing one two three four
um
so
so
so
okay
okay
okay
this
so
know
okay
so
uh
which
optical
wow
so
so
okay
so
so
so
so
check
so
so
time
hi nancy marshall ginser marketplace at
sure paul i wanna
we are in contact
uh
particularly on on on the two dissenters
but they they
consent they descended from
thank you
much
so
so
now
so
this
uh
me
oh
so
okay
see here
okay
okay
stretch
yes let's go
okay
see
cup
yes
oh
foreign
so
oh
so
[Music]
good afternoon everyone i
as some of you know just concluded a
hour and a half long briefing
with seven of our nation's top public
health experts
on the state of the pandemic the steps
we need to curb
the spread of the virus and the
challenges of distributing a
safe and effective vaccine once one is
identified
before i turn to those issues let me say
a few words about the president's
comments last night
even before acknowledging uh to bob
woodward on tape that he was fully
informed
on the gravity of the danger related to
cope at 19
he refused to warn the american people
again last night in television town hall
the president revealed in no uncertain
terms
the lack of seriousness with which he
continues to take
this pandemic nearly eight months
after this crisis on the doorstep of two
hundred thousand american deaths
president trump has refused once again
to take responsibility
or to take action by his own admission
he continued to lie about covert 19. he
doubled down
on the catastrophic mistakes that he's
made and perhaps
worst of all he made clear that he still
doesn't have a plan
to bring us out of this crisis even said
and i quote
a lot of people think that masks are not
good
undercutting the easiest most effective
means we have
for reducing the spread of this disease
this virus is still taking nearly a
thousand lives a day the forecasts show
that those numbers are likely to climb
this winter but incredibly
donald trump insists that he wouldn't
have done anything different
not one thing last friday we learned
that another one of the thousands
americans died
due to this virus and it continues to
rise
and the very same day that we reported a
thousand deaths on friday and the very
same day
canada reported that not one person
died of covet 19 in canada
trump wouldn't have done anything
differently
if you're a parent in america preparing
for another day that your
child can't attend school if you're
grieving the loss of a son a daughter a
mother a father
husband or wife if you're a small
business owner
who's on the brink of total bankruptcy
you can't open or can't go back to work
because the virus still is spreading
your community
how does it make you feel to the
president say
he wouldn't have done anything
differently
if he gets four more years why should we
expect anything to change all president
had to offer last night
president trump was the same weak and
feckless inaction
the same lies and empty promises that
we've seen from the very beginning
he still won't accept any responsibility
he still won't offer a plan
and last night he repeated what he said
so many times before
that even if he continues to offer only
failing indifference someday
the virus is going to go away by america
even if he does nothing it's going to go
away by a miracle
it won't go away like a miracle in fact
even if it get able to get a vaccine
will not be available for most
populations are well into the 2021
you know so we're heading into a very
dangerous
autumn the fact that the university of
washington model
which the white house has previously
touted projects that cases and deaths
are going to spike this november
and an additional by 215
000 americans they say you're gonna die
begin the spike in november
but by the first of the year 215 000
will be dead additional
that's more than already died we need
leadership right now to prevent that
from happening
the same university model shows the
university of washington model
shows that if if there's universal
masking
these deaths could be projected this
could be cut in half
we could say between now and the end of
the year 100
000 lives let's assume they're off by
half on all of this
50 000 lives 150 000 dead
donald trump's own director of cdc told
us that wearing a mask is a single
most important step we can take to curb
this virus
here's what he said he said i might go
so far as to say
that this face mask and he held up a
face mask not this one
is more guaranteed to protect me against
covet
than when i take a covert vaccine end of
quote
i spoke with the experts today about
additional steps we can take to prevent
needless deaths and suffering between
now and a universal vaccine being made
available
uniform national guidelines they said
and
standards on social distancing that can
be applied to
particular circumstances of states and
communities based on their
their particular circumstance more
effective approaches on
testing and tracing we do these things
between now and january
we could save even more lives last night
donald trump indicated he has no
interest in doing these things
folks the president's first
responsibility is to protect
the american people and he won't
that's utterly disqualified
i also spoke to the experts this morning
about the paramount importance of
preparing now for swift
organized and free distribution of a
safe and effective cova 19 vaccine when
it arrives
and i'm profoundly grateful to the
scientists and the researchers
working tirelessly to ensure that a safe
and effective vaccine becomes a reality
as soon as possible these scientists
carry the hopes of our nation our entire
nation
and the entire world when their work
comes to fruition and it will
there will be no doubt it will save
lives
but scientific breakthroughs don't care
about calendars
any more than the virus does they
certainly don't adhere to election
cycles
and their timing their approval and
their distribution should never ever be
distorted
by political considerations they should
be determined by
science and safety alone
a vaccine would offer a way back to
normal in a path
toward better days for all of us not
only here but around the world
but it's not going to happen overnight
once we have it it's going to take
months to distribute it to the entire
population
i'm more hopeful than ever in the power
of science to get us there
but one thing is certain we can't allow
politics
to interfere with the vaccine in any way
americans have had to endure president
trump's incompetence and dishonesty
when it comes to testing and personal
protective equipment
we can't afford to repeat those fiascos
when it comes to a vaccine
when it occurs the stakes are too high
american families have already suffered
and sacrificed
too much so let me be clear
i trust vaccines i trust
scientists but i don't trust donald
trump
at this moment the american people can't
either
last week senator harris and i
laid out three questions this
administration is going to have to
answer
to assure the american people that
politics will not play a role
whatsoever in the vaccine process
if donald trump can't give answers an
administration can't give answers these
three questions
the american people should not have
confidence but if they can
they should have confidence in the
transparency they need to trust a
vaccine and adopt it
in numbers that will make a difference
first question
what criteria will be used to ensure
that a vaccine meets the scientific
standard
of safety and effectiveness what's the
criteria
second if the administration green
lights a vaccine
who will validate that the decision was
driven by science
rather than politics what group of
scientists will that be
and thirdly how can we be sure that the
distribution of the vaccine will take
place
safely cost-free and without a hint of
favoritism
the fact of the matter is development
vaccine is only
part of the battle distributing a
vaccine to the entire population is as
complex and challenging as one of the
most sensitive military operations
i've been calling for an effective
distribution plan to be laid out for
months
i'm elected president i'll begin by
implementing an effective distribution
plan
from the minute i take office
that's what i discussed with the experts
in the briefing today
they laid out a clear plan they include
a detailed timetable for when people
will get the vaccine
clear deniation of priority of
populations to get the vaccine
a specific means and mechanism for
shipping
and storing vaccine in appropriate
temperatures
two of those vaccines if they're come
forward they have to be
stored and shifted 70 degrees below zero
the division of responsibility at every
level of government
has to be clear and i will provide the
leadership necessary to carry out that
plan
i'll level with the american people i'll
take responsibility
and i'll support rather than tear down
the experts responsible
for the day-to-day execution of the plan
i'll simply
follow the science the satisfactory
answer to these two
these three questions that senator
harris and i have laid out
every american including me and my
family can have confidence
in a safe and effective covenanting
vaccine
this isn't about politics it's about
saving lives
it's about getting back to our loved
ones and our friends
making sure they're safe it's about
getting our economy back on his feet
getting back to the movie theaters and
restaurants and ballparks
it's about getting back to our lives and
getting america up off the mat
i'm confident we can and will be united
in that pursuit
no matter when that breakthrough emerges
in vaccines no matter
when that hope bears fruit that's what
america does at its best
we unite we do it together and i'm
confident we'll be able to
just want to thank you god bless our
scientists and researchers
and our frontline workers and may god
protect our troops
i'll be happy to take some questions now
if that's uh
okay let me put my list here
everybody's sitting
okay
abc mary
thank you mr vice president you just
said that when it comes to a vaccine you
don't trust
donald trump is there a risk that that
message that questioning the president
on a vaccine could prevent people
from trusting the science from trusting
a vaccine when there finally is one no
because i know he doesn't have any
respect for scientists he basically said
you saw what he said when he was out in
california about wildfires and
scientists don't know and it's going to
go away like a miracle it's necessary
so people can trust the vaccine
and that's why i said that you have to
have this board of scientists or
they're going to say this is why we
think this is a good vaccine
why it's approved and has to be total
transparency
so scientists outside the government
know exactly
what is being approved the context in
which it's being approved
and why it's being approved i think it's
the only thing that takes care of that
for a vaccine to work though to be
effective you do need a certain amount
of the population
to be willing to take it you're saying
don't trust the president
trust me if i'm elected are you more
confident than enough america
trust the scientists trust
the scientists it's one thing for donald
trump to say the vaccine is safe
okay then give it to the board of
scientists
have total transparency so independent
operators and scientists and companies
go out and take a look at it
and what did you base that decision on
what did you do did you pressure
the head of the fda did you pressure
whomever i'm not saying you would or
will
but that's what has to happen because
you know yourself you all know the polls
better than i do
the american people right now don't
trust
what the president says about things
relating to science
and if the scientists say a vaccine
under the president's watch is safe and
effective absolutely
do it yes if those three questions i
laid out can be answered yes
absolutely
um caitlyn cbs
thank you mr vice president just a quick
follow-up on that
you say that you don't trust the
president does that mean you also don't
trust the cdc
and the fda currently no
i don't trust some of the people like
the fella
who just took a leave of absence from
the cdc he didn't run it but he was a
spokesperson for it
but there are some when i met with the
seven scientists today
on the screen here in this room they
told me the people that they had worked
with
in the cdc and the fda and all the
various
agencies there's some very very good
people there in the ranks the everyday
folks that are not every day they're
scientists but the people
who do the daily work in there there's
some very very good people
but you know from other items that
they've been squashed and things they've
said
and they've been pressured the heads of
those agencies politically appointed
some of them
have been in fact moved moved to say yes
we can do this or that or this will work
or that work
it's a simple proposition if
your evapo is ready to go
it should be totally transparent the
basis upon which that decision was
made washed and things they've said and
they've been pressured
and outside the government and said this
is a useful safe vaccine to
take so you gotta say what i'm saying
and that's gonna
and that's gonna be necessary i'd
respectfully suggest no matter what i
said
in this process because all the pulling
down
because all the polling data is only 30
some percent of america if trump said
it's okay
this is the guy the same guy that said
inject leech this is the same guy
you know you want to keep hurricanes you
know
you want to keep hurricanes to the
united states why don't we drop a new i
mean
you know there's a quick question on the
economy uh the feds is for unemployment
er
we actually created more jobs in the
last three years of our administration
he created the first
four years of his administration we
actually had more equitable distribution
among middle class folks and the like
there were fewer people at risk but i
think it's a matter of my being able to
communicate
my position on jobs and trade and what i
would do and
you know for example the world trade
organization he loves to batter us
around
and we've supported the world trade or
just ruled that his trade policies were
illegal
well guess what we went in with 14 15 16
times at the wto when we won every
single time
now why should any american remember
that that was you know
five six seven eight years ago so part
of it is reminding people and laying out
for them
what my plan for economic recovery is
but if people have
questions about the economic fallout
from the pandemic now
you have said that you would have acted
earlier
what do you say to people who might
question how the economic impact
could have been different even if you
acted earlier the
social distancing and the closings would
still be in place
no not necessarily because you wouldn't
be having the high rates of
of reinfection that we have now you
wouldn't be having a thousand people a
day die
you'd be able to open we need national
guidance as of the basis upon which you
can open up
and it depends it varies within state to
state
so you may very well be able to open up
in a rural area not a
not a area that is a metropolitan area
or vice versa
because of the the degree to which the
virus is rampant in that area
we've not set anything out we've not
laid out as this administration has not
laid out the criteria
there's no national criteria what's the
national criteria for opening schools
they still don't have one you need a
national criteria
and you need to be able to be sure
excuse me that you can
open safely and securely you can have
social distancing
you can have the wearing of mass you can
have smaller classes you need more
teachers a whole range of things
but why won't he lay out the guidance
and even when the cdc initially
had stronger guidance what happened talk
about political manipulation
he said no no don't put those out don't
put those
out because the president was then
saying by the way testing just causes
more
cause it causes more cases to show it's
about being honest
you know he loves to quote churchill he
loves to quote
roosevelt well you know roosevelt said
in a crisis in world war ii he said it's
going to get
worse and worse and worse till it gets
better and better and better the one
thing you have to tell the american
people they're strong
give it to them straight straight from
the shoulder they can handle anything
that's what i'll do
um cnn
jessica thanks mr vice president uh you
mentioned the cdc director's comments
this morning about the vaccine and how
i'm sorry about masks and how critical
they are you've previously called for a
mask mandate a national mask mandate
if you were elected what steps would you
take to put that in place and and how
would that work
well first of all i found it fascinating
the president said and biden
didn't put in a mass mandate i don't
know how old he's about you
i'm not the president he's the president
it's like you know biden's problems in
these cities are inflamed
i'm not the president he's the president
i would make
i would call all the governors to the
white house
and say and because there's a question i
think it can be answered in the positive
a question whether i can mandate
over state lines that every single state
has to comply
our legal team thinks i can do that
based upon the degree to which there's a
crisis
in those states and how bad things are
for the country
and if we don't do it what happens but i
would make the case
i'd make the case why it's necessary i'd
have the scientists to raid to lay out
in detail why and i would go to every
governor
and i'd go to governors related
republican and democratic governors and
i'd say
we have to have this national mandate
we must do it and at a minimum what i
would do
i wouldn't walk around saying mass don't
matter like he said it's your town hall
i think it was last night i saw the tail
end of it that
well you know uh you know mass you know
people don't don't like mask matter of
fact they could be worse
and i think don't hold me to this
because they didn't see it as what
reported
and they yeah and stephanopoulos asked
why
and he said because waiters don't like
him waiters touch the food and touch the
mask i mean
come on but what would happen if say
a republican governor pushed back on you
on this
how do you get buy-in when it's become
so politicized would you sign an
executive order
well the question is whether i have the
legal authority as president signed an
executive order we think we do but i
don't i can't guarantee you that yet
but if you did you would if i did i
would thank you sir
thank you number five uh i have to call
on
my hometown paper the news journal
meredith
sir in terms of the distribution of the
virus
communities of color have been greatly
affected would they get access to the
virus first how would that work in terms
of the distribution of
americans being able to get the virus
based on the proposal laid out
by the experts i spoke of today and
the national science foundation is
coordinating with the cdc
and other agencies they indicate that
the first
group of people that should get the
vaccine if and when it is available
are people at the greatest risk and that
includes everything from nursing homes
to people with serious pre-existing
conditions that would cause
people to be in real trouble a lot of
those people happen to be black and
brown
happen to be black and brown and so
it would be based upon the degree of
explosion it would go
first though i would argue but i
have a scientific board laid out for me
it would go
first as laid out for me today to
first responders doctors and nurses the
people who most
we're most needed to have available to
deal with our crises
health as well as physical crises in in
our communities
that would be the first and it would
move to the least
now one thing that hasn't happened yet
and
uh i don't want to and i am not a
scientist although i hope i'm well
informed on this issue
there have been no tests yet on children
so children ironically may be the last
people
to get the vaccine because it's going to
take time
in the they indicated to me in 2021
to be able to do the kind of testing on
children
children are less likely to die although
they can
and it's more likely that their teachers
and the elderly prayer elderly
grandparents etc would be exposed
so the first would go to the people most
susceptible
but children are going to have to be
part of this but there's a lot more work
that has to be done there but no trials
done yet on children
and today the government released a plan
and how they would or
a loose plan on how they would
distribute the vaccine
if you're elected would you reverse
course on the plan that the federal
government has already put in place
no they haven't put one in place for
real yet number one number two i haven't
seen the detail of it and it may be
it may be a very good plan as is but
what i would do is make sure
that i brought in all of the experts to
make sure what is the best
and most rad most rational means of
distribution
now look there are two types of vaccines
being worked on now one is an rna
model that are done by two of the
of the operations i think moderna and uh
um i figured which one who has the other
one
and the other is an adenovirus which is
a way to
generate the immune system to respond
one changes the cell structure
the one that deals with the the the the
mrna
that requires two injections
and it requires to be stored at 70
degrees below zero
so in addition to all this there are
mechanical issues
as to how and where the vaccine assuming
let's say the moderna one is picked
assuming
that the vaccine is approved it's a very
very significant difficult problem how
you distribute that vaccine for example
you couldn't you have to ship it in bulk
if it's if it's the
mrna version and that means
you know thousands of a thousand at a
time kind of thing
that means it's going to go to hospitals
and major distribution
medical distribution centers it's not
going to go to your doctor
like you and you can't show up at
walgreens like i did the other and i did
my doc gave it to me but my flu shot but
i used to get my flu shot at walgreens
you can't do that because you can't do
it in small lots
you have to have two shots two of them
and so my generic point is there are a
lot of
not only what is safe to do but
distribution issues that are
consequential and matter a lot
and so it's not like by the way if i
told you tomorrow if i said if i were
president said
we have approved the following two
vaccines or one vaccine
well the vaccines that are likely to be
approved so far
are start off with a a group of 10
000 doses all the way to 60 000 doses
well you know there are millions of
people it's going to take and then you
get up to several million
but it takes time is what i'm saying
and it has to be done fairly and well
it can't be based on your tax returns
figuratively speaking
it's got to be based on who is most
vulnerable who is most vulnerable okay
thank you all so very very much thank
you
mr ryden do you plan to give anyone uh
any cabinet decisions before the
election